Trascrizione: Sara Pasini
Nel 1500, in quella parte
dell’Europa del Nord
che corrisponde più o meno
a Olanda e Belgio,
le città erano ricchissime:
mercanti, banchieri, gioiellieri,
proprietari di navi.
E tutta questa borghesia molto ricca
chiamava nelle sue case, nelle sue corti
dei pittori
che dipingessero la magnificenza
delle case, la ricchezza dei vestiti.
Quasi tutti.
Ma uno, questo,
Pieter Bruegel non si curava di questo.
Si preoccupava del fatto che i suoi
concittadini non si accorgessero
di quello che accadeva attorno a loro,
che fossero concentrati egoisticamente
sui loro interessi.
E lui dipinge questo quadro, vedete.
C’è il proprietario terriero coi panni
curiali che ara guardando davanti a sé.
Poi c’è un pastore che guarda in alto,
un pescatore che guarda in basso,
vascelli che vanno.
Un paesaggio idilliaco, ma stiamo attenti.
In fondo a destra
c’è una gamba che sporge.
Icaro sta affogando.
Un ragazzo che ha cercato di sconfiggere
la legge di gravità,
si è incollato le ali sulle spalle
con della cera,
è riuscito a volare, ma
il sole ha sciolto la cera
e il ragazzo è precipitato, sta annegando.
Il primo uomo che ha cercato
di volare sta annegando.
Nessuno se ne accorge.
C’è stata l’indifferenza.
Nessuno si è preso cura.
E poi quest’altro quadro,
questo è la salita al Calvario,
sempre di Pieter Bruegel.
È difficile scorgere Cristo qui in mezzo.
Guardate in tutti questi quadri,
se ricordate, se avete in mente
c’è Gesù in prima fila, sul primo piano
e poi gli altri. Qui invece no.
Qui Gesù è disperso in mezzo agli altri.
Lo si vede appena.
E gli altri sono distratti.
In basso a destra c’è la madre di Gesù
con le sue amiche che piange,
signori che tornano dalla caccia,
bambini che giocano, gente distratta.
Sta accadendo una cosa straordinaria.
Un uomo di poco più di trent’anni
che ha cambiato le sorti dell’Occidente,
la cultura, le idee, il modo di agire,
che ha detto le beatitudini.
Beati i poveri di spirito, beato chi
ha fame e sete di giustizia.
Che vuol dire prendetevi cura di quelli
che hanno fame e sete di giustizia,
di quelli che sono poveri di spirito.
Ecco, quest'uomo sta andando al patibolo,
ma nessuno se ne accorge.
Vedete l'indifferenza?
L’indifferenza, il contrario
di prendersi cura.
Gramsci aveva scritto:
“Io odio gli indifferenti”.
Io odio gli indifferenti.
E qual è stata la prima, qual è la prima
vittima dell’indifferenza oggi?
È l’ambiente?
Pensate che per la prima volta
nella storia dell’umanità,
su un milione di particelle dell’atmosfera
poco meno di 500 sono di anidride
carbonica. E continua a crescere.
Sapete questo che vuol dire,
che noi alleviamo i nostri figli e nipoti
in modo che siano caldi d’inverno,
che se possibile facciano un po’ di
vacanza d’estate, che giochino,
che imparino se possibile una lingua,
che vadano bene a scuola,
si costruiscano un futuro.
Però in quale mondo
vivranno questi ragazzi
se non cambiamo
i nostri comportamenti?
Avranno più tumori.
Avranno più malattie della pelle,
più malattie degli occhi.
E quindi, se vogliamo avere cura di loro,
dobbiamo avere cura dell’ambiente
che è una grande vittima
dell’indifferenza.
Ma la maggiore vittima dell’indifferenza,
o meglio del non avere cura,
è la democrazia.
Guardate questa immagine. Vedete?
Nel 2005 i paesi liberi erano 89.
Nel 2020 sono 82, sono diminuiti.
I paesi parzialmente liberi
da 58 sono passati a 59.
I paesi non liberi sono cresciuti
di molto, dal 45 al 54.
Oggi il 60% della popolazione mondiale
non vive in condizioni di libertà.
Vent’anni fa il 60% della popolazione
mondiale viveva in condizioni di povertà.
La democrazia è regredita.
Guardate quest'altra immagine.
La riconoscete? Sì?
È l’attacco al Congresso americano.
Cioè la più grande democrazia
dell’Occidente non è stata in grado
di frenare una masnada di facinorosi
che ha invaso il luogo
della rappresentanza
del più grande paese
del mondo occidentale.
Non è stata capace di curare se stessa,
di curare la struttura della democrazia,
il fondamento della democrazia.
Una cosa del genere è accaduta in Italia.
A Roma un gruppo di facinorosi ha invaso
con la violenza, ha distrutto
la Camera del Lavoro di Roma.
Come qui a Torino nei primi anni venti
un gruppo di facinorosi assaltò
la Camera del Lavoro, la distrusse,
bruciò tutti i documenti.
Perché non si era avuto il tempo e la
voglia di prestare cura ai valori
della democrazia e quindi
era cresciuta la non democrazia.
Vedete, la democrazia
non vive soltanto di classi dirigenti.
Ha bisogno di cittadini democratici.
Che vuol dire cittadini democratici?
Cittadini che abbiano cura di sé
e degli altri
che operano a cura delle istituzioni.
Racconta Tocqueville nel
Viaggio in America
che la differenza tra gli europei
e americani era questa.
Se i cittadini di uno Stato europeo si
accorgono che c’è un buco nella strada,
cosa fanno?
Si riuniscono insieme e fanno un corteo
per protestare davanti al sindaco.
Negli Stati Uniti i cittadini si
riuniscono e si mettono d’accordo
su come colmare la buca.
Sono due modi diversi di guardare le cose.
I secondi si prendono cura e questo
è tanto importante, prendersi cura.
E forse voi ricorderete che due ragazzine
qualche giorno fa hanno aggredito,
insultato, picchiato un loro compagno
perché ebreo.
Gli hanno detto: “Ti aspettano i forni”.
Una signora che è morta a Roma
ha chiesto che sulla sua bara ci fosse
la bandiera nazista.
Guardate, sapete che nel 2021
ogni tre giorni è stata uccisa una donna.
Ogni tre giorni è stata uccisa una donna.
Ci saranno le pene, i processi etc,
ma guardate non basta.
Bisogna educare ai valori.
Perché il processo, la pena, la giustizia
serve al male di ieri.
Noi dobbiamo prevenire il male di domani,
e il male di domani si prevede educando,
avendo cura degli altri.
C’è una cosa che mi ha molto colpito.
Un importante archeologo tedesco ha
scoperto nel nord dell’Iraq negli anni ’60
il corpo, i resti di una persona
che era vissuta all’età di Neanderthal
60.000 anni fa.
Gli studi successivi hanno scoperto
una cosa, pensate che quest’uomo
era morto più o meno a 40 anni.
40 anni di allora era come 80 di adesso.
Quindi aveva vissuto a lungo.
Era privo di una mano. Era zoppo.
Aveva la tempia sfondata e
probabilmente sordo e senza un occhio.
Ma era vissuto, sapete perché?
Gli altri della sua tribù
avevano avuto cura di lui.
Mi ha colpito invece che qualche mese fa
è stata scoperta una signora
che era morta da mesi in casa sua
e nessuno se n’era accorto.
Perché nessuno aveva avuto cura di lei.
E guardate questo, avere cura è una cosa
fondamentale, avere cura di altri.
Vuol dire avere anche cura di se stessi,
preoccuparsi degli altri.
E guardate non ci sono
solo esempi negativi.
Pensate ai medici e gli infermieri
durante il Covid.
Quanto hanno rischiato e quanti sono
morti per avere cura degli altri?
Pensate agli insegnanti che si sono
attrezzati a fare didattica a distanza.
Guardate io penso che noi consegnamo
figli e nipoti a un ceto professionale
che ritiene da 6 anni a 24-25
a un ceto professionale
al quale non riconosciamo dignità sociale.
Non abbiamo cura di chi cura,
educa i nostri figli, i nostri nipoti.
Questo è grave.
Bisogna avere cura per loro.
(Applausi)
Non è solo un problema di retribuzione.
È un problema di attenzione a quello che
accade, a quello che succede attorno a noi
Infine, forse voi ricorderete quello che
è accaduto trent’anni fa.
Trent'anni fa.
Non c’è bisogno di commentare.
Riconoscete questo, immagino.
Quei due magistrati sono morti
perché avevano avuto cura
della democrazia.
Cura della giustizia,
cura della legalità.
E permettetemi di leggere i nomi
di una ragazza e di alcuni ragazzi.
I nomi di Falcone, di Borsellino
li conoscete tutti.
Vi leggo degli altri nomi.
Vito Schifani.
Rocco Dicillo.
Antonio Montinaro.
Agostino Catalano.
Walter Cusina.
Emanuela Loi.
Claudio Traina.
Vincenzo Li Muli.
Morti con loro.
(Applausi)
Morti con loro,
E guardate, in una democrazia
non ci possono essere morti
di serie A e di serie C.
Non è possibile.
Non è possibile dimenticarli.
E guardate che
uomini come Falcone, Borsellino sapevano
che se fossero stati uccisi ci sarebbero
state scuole, piazze, funerali di Stato,
onori, ricordi, memorie.
Ma quegli altri sapevano che non ci
sarebbe stato niente per loro.
(Applausi)
Sapete per che cosa sono morti?
Per una parola che non si pronuncia più.
Per una parola che si chiama patria.
Patria.
Guardate, patria non quella delle nazioni
violente, aggressive e militari, no.
La patria della Costituzione,
quella che dice che siamo uguali,
che abbiamo diritto al lavoro, alla
sicurezza, all’istruzione, alla salute.
E che dobbiamo lavorare insieme
per far crescere il nostro Paese.
Loro lo hanno fatto e cerchiamo...
In questi trent'anni ci saranno
un sacco di cerimonie, credo.
E un sacco di retorica.
Stiamo attenti perché il modo per onorare
quelle persone non è celebrare un giorno.
È ricordare ogni giorno
quello che hanno fatto
per cercare di essere degni di loro.